So one thing, if you remember back to what we did when we
needed to update our map that we forgot to do with the buttons,
was make sure that we properly update any elements that are no longer active.
I say active, in this sense, to mean any buttons that don't correspond to
the current year, and any countries that don't correspond to
the current year of the World Cup that we're looking at, and
any circles that don't correspond to the current year we're looking at.
For our map, we did this update through the exit selection.
We filtered our data for the year of interest, we removed elements from our
exit selection and we added elements from our enter selection.
For the buttons, for the sake of simplicity, we can make all the buttons change
to their initial state and then selectively change the one button we need.